[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
what's up Prof I'm going to jump ahead
of you how are you Martin I'm doing well
thank you and you I'm doing fine too
thank you uh we want to build on what
we've did last time um once again it's a
very important subject and I think one
that's very
misunderstood so let's open with a word
of prayer yes there's a lot of confusion
about the issue and uh there are so many
viewpoints so let's
pray our heavenly father once again we
are here and we ask that you help us
that we can do this discussion that it
can be enlightening to everybody and
that we can do it to honor your name in
Jesus name we pray amen
amen Martin if I
may start off with an
idea and that is that everything in
scripture has to do with worship that's
true
yeah and it has to do with
trust who do you believe who do you
trust and one of the issues in the very
beginning was distrust did God really
say isn't that distrust totally
okay uh or let's put it another way who
is he to tell you that yeah so that's a
rebellion right and that's the portion
that happened in heaven with yes yeah
I'll tell him how it should
be so it's not just a question of
questioning what God has said it's
also attacking what God has said and
turning it on its
head so we're going to talk about the
kingdom and there are many views
regarding the kingdom of
heaven and if you go back to the time
when Jesus walked upon this Earth he
said the Kingdom of Heaven is near yeah
because it it basically has come down to
you yeah referring to to himself
himself so you cannot divorce the
Kingdom from the
king and you cannot replace the king
with another king an interim
King is either the king or is not the
king yeah it's like that uh the age-old
battle between England and
Scotland yes you know when England
decided to break from the
papacy they set up a monarch
MH in the place of the
papacy so the king of England became the
head of the church yeah so what had he
done he' actually duplicated the papacy
yeah uh yes in Europe the the kings were
subject to the pope yeah and England was
subject to the pope as the Magna cata
and all of these things
show uh their their fear of the papacy
but eventually it came to the point
where they broke with the papacy and the
King set himself up in the place of the
papacy and then there were the
Relentless Wars with
Scotland because Scotland refused to
acknowledge it yeah and uh the Scots
said one of their battle cries was we
have no King save
Jesus now that's not a bad Battle Cry
right no that's a very good one that's
actually the one that we are supposed to
have as as
well so the kingdom people have
different views of the kingdom and then
you came
to uh the Protestant Reformation I just
wanted to say if the Jews at the time of
Jesus had the
same saying as the Scots had it would
have probably ended a lot better it
would have ended a lot better yes but
they their Earthly
kingdom was placed inject the position
to the Heavenly Kingdom yeah they had no
they had no room for the Heavenly
Kingdom because the Heavenly Kingdom
requires a change of heart isn't that
the problem that is exactly what the
problem is whereas an Earthly Kingdom
you can still get by with your Fallen
nature yeah yeah you can sight step a
few things all right so in the Middle
Ages the the church ruled with an iron
hand and the Reformation rebelled
against against it and they set up
exactly the same system yes church and
state and if you lived in a Protestant
Canton and you were catholic you had to
get out of there and if you lived in a
Catholic Canton and you wanted to be a
Protestant you had to get out of there
or else you could you could literally
lose your head right yeah so it was just
a opposite system but still a duplicate
yes but was it was it really the kingdom
of God no for every tribe and nation and
you know all of these things so we're
talking about thy kingdom come it's part
of the prayer isn't that part of the
Lord's Prayer of
course thy in thy will be done on Earth
as it is in heaven so whose kingdom is
it God's kingdom Jesus's kingdom was it
ever intended to be an Earthly Kingdom
no if if it had ever been intended to be
an Earthly Kingdom wouldn't Jesus have
set it up wouldn't it have been the
perfect timing to do it exactly then he
would have been here because he's the
king what does it help the kingdom is
here but the king is not here correct
did he get rid of Caesar no no he said
Render unto Caesar what is Du unto
Caesar and unto God what is due unto God
so there are two opposites there yeah
and when it came to a conflict of
interest between what God required and
what the Earthly Kings required then you
had to choose the Heavenly rather than
the Earthly right yeah yeah so when the
Pharisees said to the disciples you will
not preach in this name mhm is does it
seem right to you that we should listen
to man rather than to God nope that's
why they continued so they continued did
they get into trouble oh a lot of
trouble yes yes they got into a lot of
trouble did they tried to kill them yes
did they actually killed them they
actually did they left them for dead and
Herod actually
killed that's they actually did the
literal killing as well yeah yes so it's
it's fascinating so we need to talk
about this Kingdom so let's just start
again it's an issue of worship it
started off with who do you worship and
who do you believe yeah we did that with
the Sabbath story that's so you've got a
requirement yes are you adhering it to
acknowledge who are you worshiping is it
going to be the same in the end yes
so the end issue has to be an issue of
worship yeah who do you
worship exactly and if it's not then
there's no consistency in the Bible true
so if it's all about computers and
banking systems rather than worship then
there's something seriously arai yeah
would you agree yeah then it becomes man
again it you we become a the gods all
right was it a a conflict of who do you
believe and who do you obey yes in the
beginning mhm then wouldn't it be
logical that the conflict will be who do
you believe and whom do you obey exactly
the same what's the first Angel's
message worship God who created and give
glory to him for the hour of his
judgment has come worship Him who
made judgment implies a law yeah implies
obedience
worship Him who made it's exactly the
same issue as in Eden right exactly okay
so let's talk about the
kingdom now Martin here's an interesting
article and it's pretty new as you can
see it's from the 22nd of the 6th month
2024 and the question is can gree's new
sixday work week be a model for
others in Greece new regulations are
coming into effect on July the 1st that
make this
possible for those impacted it would
mean a normal legal work week of 48
Hours instead of the previous 40 in
theory employees can choose to work more
if companies want them to those who work
more will also be paid more and then
there's the question can this be a role
model for other count
countries now if we go back a little bit
in history when Greece was in dire
Financial Straits yes between 2009 that
was yes 2009 round about there I forget
the exact date but the point is they
were placed under very strict guidelines
and restrictions by the European banking
powers that bailed them out yeah so the
people that gave them the money had
rules that comes with the money yes and
one of the rules
was that they would basically have to
work this six day work week yeah in the
meantime European countries have been
experimenting with four and uh other
work there is the Europe yeah but now
Greece is setting the pace and going
back to this work model
but uh the Constitution should also
guarantee a day of rest yeah now with a
six day work week that doesn't leave
much leeway as to which day that is
going to be mhm and if they violated
that principle when it was implemented
in 2009 there were very heavy penalties
yes if you didn't Adar so if somebody
wanted to have an exemption for whatever
a reason there wasn't much leeway to
provide that exemption and here we have
again the same situation where they've
now introduced this
model and obviously one day will be a
day of rest yeah which day will that be
marttin Sunday it will be
Sunday and because it is a six day work
week and Sunday is an obligatory day of
rest when it becomes that yeah it's
already written basically in in the gray
areas then there will be no leeway for
you to choose another day no right no so
this is very interesting can this be a
role model for other countries they're
asking this question actual fact in 2009
they already already decided that this
was going to be the role model because
it was enforced by the the the in powers
that bailed them out yeah so very
interesting development development very
interesting
indeed and then Martin there's another
very interesting development in the
United States where the state of
Louisiana has decided to make it
obligatory to put the Ten Commandments
back into the school rooms
yes and uh Republican Governor Jeff
Landry
signed the
legislation from a Catholic School
auditorium last week that's very
interesting huh it's not separated from
the Catholic
system after announcing that he can't
wait to be sued by turning Louisiana
into the first state to mandate the Ten
Commandments in
schools now this is a test gate for the
separation of church and State that's it
this is going to be a very important one
to look at but it's a it's a already a
precursor yes but it's being provocative
right it's very provocative all right
and he says he can't wait to be
sued why not because the idea is to take
it all the way up to the Supreme Court
exactly what they basically want is a
ruling by the Supreme Court that it does
not violate the separation of church
exactly and the First Amendment and the
First Amendment and if you just
speculate a little bit who's the
majority on the Supreme Court yes it's
Catholics Catholics
Catholics Louisiana Law requires all
schools to display the text exactly as
written in the bill and in a poster or
framed document that is at least at
least 11 in by 14 in at minimum and in
large easily readable
font judge herland who has two children
in New Orleans Public elementary school
said Louisiana's specific state approved
version of The Ten
Commandments are not the Commandments as
I and many Jews know them the display
spells out the name of God for example
be that as it may Martin it's
interesting that read it from a Catholic
School auditorium yeah I'm sure now the
world is actually keeping the Catholic
Commandments because they keep Sunday
holy yes that's a Catholic law as we
have seen it's not a Biblical
law so the Ten Commandments as they will
have been displayed will represent the
Catholic version definitely okay and not
the biblical version no especially when
it comes to the fourth Commandment
they'll put the short version in
correct but this is the point where we
are at there is a push to get religion
back into the system right
correct we carry on reading Rachel laser
whose group Americans United for the
separation of church and state argued at
the Supreme Court in another major First
Amendment test in
2022 said Louisiana's law is a prime
example of the CHR Christian
nationalism that is on the march across
this country from mandating religious
displays in schools to supporting book
bands and installing chaplain in
classrooms the political ideology is the
fundamental threat to our democracy she
said so here is a major challenge yes is
this a challenge between the King of the
North and the King of the
South definitely definitely because this
is a prime example of that all right and
we've had all of these ideological
issues running in the background of late
and so there was this uh political
cartoon if we can say it that way that
was publicized and here's a teacher with
something in her hand and she says in
schools
outrageous and she pastes this poster
over it so is it a moral issue
oh for sure and this is again a prime
example of King of the North King of the
South it's two ideologies yeah now if
you have trashed the King of the South
ideology by taking it from the sublime
to the
ridiculous and this is
basically what the argument is right you
have all the transgender issues these
are there to fray the nerves of people
for sure and push them in a Direction
it's a very nice heelan
dialectic and it's very easy to climb
onto the bandwagon you can be sucked
into this and make yourself a soap box
especially when you read the Bible when
you're a Christian then this is the type
of thing that will suck you in very
quickly okay is it a question of worship
it yeah it is there is a question of
worship all right there's something else
here uh if you look at the way it's
portrayed here even in the
cartoon and you look at it here the two
tables of stone is this how it's
portrayed in the Bible five on one and
five on the other no no right no it's
four six it's
46 and the very long ones are here on
the first table referring to your duty
towards God mhm and there are only four
the fourth one being the Sabbath
commandment but here there are five
five and uh you can be pretty sure that
the Sabbath will not be the Sabbath but
the Sunday right that's it because
there's there are so many movements that
attach the Sunday to the issue exactly
that would be the one that only States
remember to keep the Sabbath day holy
and that's where it ends so not linking
it to the seventh day where it says
because God was your creator all right
if this becomes a state law
and it is the same as the Catholic
version then who receives the worship
the Catholic church the church receives
the worship and they worshiped him this
Beast doesn't the Bible say they
worshiped
him and uh in other places the Bible
says he that you obey you are subject to
yeah so if you are obedient to a wrong
cause then you are subject to a wrong
cause right that's it
so it is a religious issue of
worship and it has been portrayed in
such a fashion that people are riled up
and ready to take the law into their own
hands that's it so you got a lot of
people supporting and a lot of people
that's on board with this and you got a
lot of them on the secular side almost
but then there are also some that sees
there's red lights for this there's no
room for legislation in God of God's
laws yes but the the trouble is those
that see that there is something wrong
with it are unfortunately a large number
of them are on the Dr drag queen
waveling exactly and the abortion
wavings and the you know transgender
wavelength and the etc etc Etc they
don't see the real issue
mhm the issue is who do you
worship the system the world's laws and
moral issues or Gods yeah that's the
real
issue so maybe you can we can just make
it clear again don't get suck suck into
this no don't get sucked in don't get
sucked into the
ideology uh personally you would say
well I Rejoice that the Ten Commandments
are getting a place again exactly but
you can't Rejoice if they're the wrong
ones a problem
okay so they referred in that article
that there is a rise of Christian
nationalism we've been talking about
this for a long time long long time but
you can't divorce Christian nationalism
from dominionism yes that they are
linked like Siamese twins
yeah no inable Christian nationalism can
be a sentiment yeah but dominionism is a
law okay you have have to explain that
for us yeah all right so when you come
to the point of dominionism then you
have made your Christian
nationalism obligatory uhhuh you have
forced it upon the people yeah so that
is church and state enforcing yes so you
know we have the war of the flag mhm
some people want to burn the flag some
people want to kneel on one KNE knee
when it comes to the National infant
that's that's a war between nationalism
or non-national
ismh but once you've made it a law then
it becomes dominionism because you have
a rule yeah so let's say that there are
many that are inclined to take their
Christian nationalism to the next level
m and enforce it then they are
dominionist yes I understand okay so
here we have an article that is also
interesting it comes from November
already but uh it says the Christian
Century the quiet rise of Christian
dominionism now a quiet rise is that a a
movement that is working in darkness yes
it's a beautiful statement in the spirit
of prophecy about something else that's
happening in darkness a movement now in
those days Jerry fwell was still very
prominent and he wanted to prepare
America for the end of the
world and Ted Cruz's Evangelical backers
want to take America over this is very
interesting now I don't know who the
vice president is going to be m
but is he on the short list
yes de Cruz is also and irrespective of
whether he makes the cut or not is going
to be part of the team yeah so let's
read what they say over again here Cruz
who has suggested he might run in
2024 represents a more recently ascended
Evangelical worldview quite different
from
dispensationalism you see
dispensationalism and we've been talking
about it a lot and U Marlo and Robert
have also been speaking about it a lot
dispensationalism believes that the
Christian church will be raptured and
won't be part of the kingdom dominionism
is totally different it's quite
different from dispensationalism because
the Christians are actually ruling yes
down here so isn't it fascinating
how two diametrically opposed
ideologies can be bad fellows yeah yes
there there supporting each other
because both of them are taking you away
from the TRU but both of them want the
Christian
ascendancy the one just wants to take it
to heaven and the other one wants to
rule down here on Earth but they're bed
fellows because they have the same
nationalism Christian
nationalism as a as a as a common base
so the same laws they will both
appreciate yes so let's say they make an
accord and sit in a room and decide to
work together the one will say well I'll
work for this cause even though I will
be raptured away yeah and the other one
says all right I'll work for this cause
and eventually implement it that's it
that's the difference between the two
right yeah but isn't it strange Martin
that two so different IDE IES can be bed
fellows reminds me of ecumenism yes
where you can have the biggest gaps
between
ideologies and focus on one or two
things that you have in common and then
throw the baby out with a bath water you
see that's the big trap of this has
always been you just have to find a
common ground somewhere then you can
compromise on something else and then
you've got it all wrong all right this
iism Martin and
[Music]
dispensationalism would it be
interesting if they come from the same
stable I I don't think it's a a surprise
it's not a secret no it's not a secret
all right so dispensationalism who
refined it basically through the Jesuit
system all right they used a few
Protestants to to voice it but uh it
comes from the Jesuit stable
but they've always been dominionists
from the beginning yes the Roman
Catholic Church the Catholic church has
to rule it has to rule and they they are
amillennialists so they will rule
forever basically that's what it's bound
to go to so what is Christian
dominionism dominionism is the belief
that Christians should take moral
spiritual and ecclesiastical control
over Society control over Society does
that imply
action definitely
okay it has risen rather quietly in
American
society and it has had no major public
battles with
dispensationalism you see the B fellows
yeah instead the two have come to
overlap in interesting ways as indicated
by Cruz's warm reception at Liberty
individual evangelicals do not
necessarily ascribe to one or the other
so it doesn't matter what diversity you
have but the ones who seem to be in
government today are inclined towards
dominionism yeah yeah they want it to be
they want to rule from there now does
this tickle your prophetic insights oh
for sure doesn't this make your antenna
go up it is it shows you that this
prophetic pendulum is definitely all
right and here are people that are very
prominent that are even on a potential
vice
president uh ticket now we don't know
who that's going to be even if it's only
a week from now that they're going to
announce it this will not be outdated
because he'll be part of the team part
of the team and they all part of that
project
2025 absolutely absolutely it's it's
basically written there in the book yeah
I think they're going to place it beside
AR for sure it's a big document over 900
Pages all right let's jump to 2024 May
29 so this is also a very recent article
from the northeastern Global News who
are the dominionists backing
conservative candidates a growing number
of religious congregations espouse an
ideology called
dominionism that calls for Christians to
control or be the primary influence in
American government who are the
dominionists and what do they mean for
the future of
democracy uh Sarah ricardi Schwartz an
assistant professor of religion and
anthropology at North easn in
Massachusetts writer and researcher
Frederick claxon said that the once
obscure movement has been gaining
political power in the past decades and
is a player in local and national
elections across the the United States
have we been saying this for years and
years and years years and years that it
will happen yes is it happening and we
didn't think it out of our bullet out of
our thumbs no we got it out of the
scriptures yeah it's an issue of worship
for sure all right it's a utopian end
time
eschatology most dominionist but not all
emphasize that the Christian church WIll
mature and flourish and gain dominance
in society before Christ returns that's
basically what it
is is this what the Roman Catholic
Church aspires to yes that they've
always said it did it receive a mortal
wound yes was it held back for a couple
of centuries it ruled and then it got
the moral wound and it got it started to
heal in 1929 again yes obviously it will
completely be healed by this time
completely healed and uh Protestant
America will Aid in that process because
they will give their power unto the
Beast isn't that right that's so Martin
it's always interesting to me that when
you look at prophecy and you look at the
Bible people want to add whatever their
opinion is a beast is a kingdom yeah and
it describes which one it is and it is a
king that stands for that Kingdom which
monarchy key are we talking about here
the papacy the papacy cuz that is the
one that has a religious
connotation so it continues by saying
that teaching stands in opposition to
standard Christian doctrine also called
premillennialism which suggests Christ
has to return first before a Christian
kingdom is established on Earth ricardi
schart says now Martin this is a
Source we've been preaching this for as
long as I can remember that I've been
preaching about these issues right yeah
and here is a secular source that
confirms it and
everybody disbelieves it cries say
conspiracy conspiracy theory so
dominionists endgame is creating a
Christian kingdom on Earth while we're
still
alive bottom line that that's what
they're doing and that is not that
different from what the Jews want to do
correct so M this is in opposition to
standard Christian doctrine it is in
opposition to what every ten of the
Bible speaks about they know it at least
some of them
do yeah yeah they very much informed but
the Christian world doesn't seem to know
it no and they're still going to be
dispensationalists mhm or they're going
to be
dominionists you can also call them
reconstructionists cuz they want to
reconstruct the kingdom here on Earth
yeah and according to this it's not
biblical that's it all right let's take
another article from
2022 which gives us some background on
the people that are on the short list
for whether they make it or not
irrelevant they'll be in government
Florida Governor Ronda at Hillsdale
College put on the full armor of God
stand firm against the left
schemes is that North versus
South blatantly blatantly
right it used to be just Evangelical
ministers and preachers who invoked
spiritual warfare against the left now
politicians do it as well here is Miami
Harolds Anna calos on desantis's recent
visit to Hillsdale College a liberal
arts college in Michigan while visiting
a private Christian College in Southern
Michigan that Wills influence in
National politics Governor Ronda santz
rephrased the biblical passage to
deliver a message to
conservatives put on the full armor of
God stand firm against the left
schemes that's a little bit of a
rephrasing right you will face flaming
arrows but if you have the shield of
Faith you will overcome them and in
Florida we walk the line here the SST
told the audience at Hillsdale College
in February and I can tell you this I
have only begun the
fight is it a war yeah no for sure is it
a war they are preparing that what did
that um governor of Louisiana said I'm
looking forward to be taken to court
that's also he wants the war he wants it
to go all the way to the Supreme Court
so M there's been a lot of preparation
in all of this it's come up quietly but
we've talk talked now about dffs and
we've talked about Cruz both of them
have dominionist ideologies it's quite
clear let's go to Politico 2024 election
Trump allies prepare to infuse Christian
nationalism in second
Administration are we progressing for
sure they're part of this whole this
whole uh movement isn't it fascinating
that even within our own ranks we have
ostrich
theologians who sit with their and
administrators who sit with their heads
in the sand and refuse to acknowledge
that this is happening before their very
eyes yeah it's actually sad and that
video of the G7 meeting and how
everybody
bowed down and reverence the pope as he
was wheeled in in his wheelchair uhhuh
everybody was in ecstatic yes and nobody
gets the message that power is being
given unto the Beast and homage is being
paid to the system nobody gets the
message how do you not see that if you
if anybody did not see that video go and
have a watch and see the way that they
all the leaders of the world of those G7
and that's basically the important ones
of the world I I understand that someone
was brave enough to write a letter to
some of the leaders in a prominent
European country sending them that video
and saying to them basically take your
head out of the sand and stop preaching
that we are
propagating uh 19th century myths
spearheading the effort is Russell for I
don't know how to pronounce that name
but I hope I don't violate it too much
president of the center for
renewing uh does that sound like a
Reconstructionist yeah well it sounds
almost like a
reset America part of a conservative
Consortium preparing for Trump's return
to power an influential Think Tank close
to Donald Trump is developing plans to
infuse Christian nationalist ideas in
his
administration should the former
president return to power Accord
according to documents obtained by
Politico have we been preaching this
same like we just mentioned earlier
you've got also the project 2025
document that links into this this is
amazing so spearheading the effort is
this Russell fellow who served as
Trump's director of The Office of
Management and budget during his first
term and has remained close to him for
who is frequently cited as a potential
Chief of Staff in a second Trump White
House is president of of the center for
renewing America Think Tank a leading
group in a conservative Consortium
preparing for a second Trump term but is
the world ripe for this kind of thing
definitely I mean if you just take over
go over to Europe yes what we've
mentioned the whole shift to the right
and Leen that I mean that France is
after macron did that whole thing about
there has to be an election or they just
want to have a poll now they have to
have elections quite earlier he would
have been in power till 2027 yes and
it's probably going to be that he ends
in 2025 yes very everything moves I saw
an interesting thing that uh the whole
banking system is about to change in
2025 but let's not go into that we're
not part of part of the story because
the economy is going to be involved but
you know many years ago I gave a sermon
called I hear the rumbling yes that was
in Total Transformation in Total
Transformation where we spoke about the
two sieges of
Jerusalem and how they are being
replicated in 1888 there was this push
to bring in Sunday legislation and
dominionism yes and now it's coming
again it's like the second SE I I can
hear the rumbling of the Roman army very
good yeah exactly can you hear the King
of the North coming out with his fiery
chariots the rumbling of the Sunday
coming here we go there's an article
from May 18
20124 you know Martin what's so
fascinating about
prophecy is you can speculate as to how
it's going to happen yeah but the
picture becomes so clear when the news
headlines tell exactly what's going to
happen right and and look at the picture
on on this uh AP news
article Jesus is my sa is my savior
Jesus Is My Savior Trump is my president
yeah isn't this
interesting is this is this Christian
nationalism that's dominionism oh well
and the other one this is perfect this
is absolutely
perfect you know what I must let's just
people will sometimes think oh I can
already hear it or see how they write to
us so don't you want a a better life for
much better that it's Christian and not
the secularism yes but I don't want the
sting of death in it I don't want the
LIE attached to what appears to be truth
exactly and we are excited because we
understand that this is what prophecy
says has to happen has to happen yes
so Jesus is their savior Trump is their
candidate ex-president backers say he
shares Faith values as Donald Trump
increasingly infuses his campaign with
Christian
trappings while coasting to a third
Republican Presidential nomination his
support is as strong as ever among
evangelicals and other conservative
Christians Trump supports Jesus and
without Jesus America will fall said
Kimberly Vaughn of Florence now we've
just spoken about it as she joined other
supporters of the former president
entering a campaign rally near Dayton
Ohio many of the t-shirts and hats that
were worn and sold at the rally in March
proclaimed religious slogans such as
Jesus Is My Savior Trump is my president
and God Guns and TR
Trump what that doesn't even does that
match does that sound like
Jesus that sounds like when Peter cut
off the
ear very well said I'm very proud of
you one man's shirt declared make
America Godly again with the image of a
luminous Jesus putting his supportive
hands on Trump's
shoulders now
Martin I don't want to into you know the
sincerity of people or anything of that
nature but
somehow there's just something that
doesn't quite gel right true like Trump
has never admitted that he has uh
repented of his sins and Mitt Romney the
other day said he can't support him
because there are too many skeletons in
that cupboard of a of a nature that he
wouldn't want to be associated with a
presidency be that as it may I I always
want to give people the benefit of the
doubt and I don't deny their sincerity
or anything of that nature but this
sincerity is sincerely deceived that's
and that's the problem that's the
problem because you can always say like
you just mentioned yes but nobody is
without sin you you can throw all these
things but that's not there's a
deception here that's the problem
there's a deception and uh we don't have
to look at the people we have to look at
the events yes what is happening and why
is it happening so let's just go back to
that article about Louisiana to become
the first state to require the 10
commandments we've dealt with it already
we're just putting the slide there is
there an agenda here yes for sure is it
pushing the bound boundaries to bring in
dominionism yeah to get approval from
the Supreme Court maybe yeah yeah all
right let's jump to
Europe here is CNA Catholic news agency
German
president laments Church's diminished
role at catholic's
day now here is the German president
lamenting the diminishing role of the
Catholic church this is Society is in
such a mess yeah if only the church was
still involved exactly is that heading
in the same direction the same direction
and we said that this is this is what
Bible tells us that people will get so
fed up with the King of the South
mentality that they would want the King
of the North to to sweep over so here he
was steinm decribed the church's
diminishing role and standing in German
Society he called for a self-critical
debate about countering indifference to
religion and growing alienation from
institutions are the churches failing to
inspire us is their message too quiet
too neutral
nondescript steinm a Protestant noted
that committed Catholics are among the
most sturdy pillars of our Democratic
Society rooted in Freedom will
protestantism reach across the gulf and
take the hand of Rah absolutely in the
United States yeah it's already done and
in the rest of the world the rest of the
10 horns Europe countries Europe all
right and the Affiliates um Maloney is a
stor Catholic she was the one that
invited the pope to the G7 correct so
what protestantism will achieve in the
new world Catholicism will gladly accept
in the old world yeah what did he say in
his message
to the Catholic which is Catholic day
Pope Francis emphasized the event motto
the future belongs to the man of Peace a
reference to Psalms 37 Mar I have a
strange
fear that this man of Peace could be a
usurper for sure because the man of
Peace of per Psalm 37 is not the pope no
and doesn't the pope want peace in God
yes yes doesn't he want peace in Ukraine
everywhere doesn't he want to return the
children mhm I think that they're
backing the wrong horse
yeah all right the Holy Father that's a
blasphemy in
itself called for a genuine
reorientation towards God and
highlighted the interconnectedness of
various societal
crisis so if you don't bring God back in
it let's put rephrase this bring the
church back into it yes that's how they
they think of it the many moral social
economic and political crisis we are
experience are all interconnected care
for nature Justice for the poor
commitment to
society the protection of life and the
family the defense of the Dignity of all
human life as well as the outer and
inner peace all Belong Together the pope
stated now of all of these how many of
them are Christ centered
none how can you say that Martin because
it is it's is just unfortunately the
truth it's the truth right nothing no
has to do with Christ and the worship of
God nothing it's all man-made works
works every bit of it that must be an
automatic outflow from your worship to
God all right so is there something
wrong with this no no that's what I say
there's something seriously wrong you
mean I I mean if is there something
wrong to do uh justice for the poor and
no and if Essence no but the definitely
wrong that this must be the main point
or the focus exactly the cart is in
front of the horse in fact they they've
disconnected the horse completely he's
not even mentioned he's put out the
posture all right so Martin I think we
need to discuss the kingdom cuz people
are really confused we can see it by the
questions that we're getting and you
know what's wrong with it we're just
trying to reorder society and get it
back onto track yeah get it and it's
actually for God yes we're doing this
for God and if we kill you we'll be
doing God a service that's what they
said right what they said guns and God
Guns and Trump all right so Martin what
is the kingdom of God all about we need
to be rooted in
scripture yeah we need to know what it's
about and if we if we miss this point
we'll miss the
bus all right let's look at some of the
scholars of the world and let's get a
few
quotes Philip yansy is a is one of the
scholars a
theologian and he wrote a book The Jesus
I never knew let's look at his quote in
his book that Jesus I never knew laments
the fact that the kingdom of God
requires such different attitudes by its
adherence than those often displayed by
those that want to propagate it history
is replete with attempts to set up a
human equivalent of the
Kingdom he's got a point right yeah he
writes the Crusaders who pillaged the
near East the conquest do who converted
the new world at the Port of a sword the
Christian explorers in Africa who
cooperated with the slave tradeit we are
still feeling the aftershocks from their
mistakes history shows that when the
church uses the tools of the world's
kingdoms it becomes as ineffectual or as
tyrannical as any other power structure
and whenever the church has intermingled
with a state like the Holy Roman Empire
cromwell's England Calvin's Geneva the
appeal of the faith suffers as well
ironically our respect in the world
declines in proportion to how vigorously
we intemp to force others to adopt our
point of view that was very how much can
you disagree with none that's very well
put it's very well put right so there
are people that see it
but the world is rushing ahead oh yeah
and not taking any of this into account
right okay thank you Philip yansy for
that comment that doesn't mean I agree
with everything that Philip yansy has to
say but this is really spot on you know
what we always say there's a lot of
people that will open their eyes and God
will get them into the flock yes you
never know all right here's another one
this is Philip Sha very prominent uh
scholar in his history of the Christian
church he voices a very similar view
when discussing the union of church and
state under Constantine he
writes the christianizing of the state
amounted therefore in great measure to a
paganizm and secularizing of the
church temporal gain of Christianity was
in many respects cancelled by spiritual
loss church leaders considered such a
union of church and state as a
restoration of the Mosaic and davidic
theocracy on Christian
soil so he writes this in history of the
Christian Church volume 3 page 93 and
136 would you agree with them yes yes so
there are many examples in history as to
what happens when you try and do these
things for sure it's whenever and this
is the form of church and state like
we've mentioned and it's never a good
thing never a good thing and yansy seems
to agree with his Constantine idea
because he writes in that book The Jesus
I never knew ever since
Constantine the church has faced the
temptation of becoming the moral police
of
society the Catholic church in the
Middle Ages one example Calvin's
Geneva that was a catastrophe cromwell's
England Cromwell literally lost his head
eventually winthrop's New England so
even on American soil the Russian
Orthodox Church each of these has
attempted to legislate a form of
Christian morality and each has in its
own way found it hard to communicate
Grace listening to sermons and reading
the writings of contemporary churches in
the US I sometime detect more of
Constantine than of
Jesus that's also very well put would
you say it is well put yeah it's for
sure all right so we can agree with that
sentiment Martin I hope people will see
that you know it's not just us who are
voicing concerns there are many scholars
who are looking at these things and
seeing that there's something wrong and
I mean this book was written already in
1995 yeah what would they say after
those quotes that we've put onto the
screen yeah well they'll say we've
arrived we've
arrived all right so let's make a
conclusion let's say to a great extent
the reformers inherited the state and
church structures of the Church of the
Middle Ages right mhm and never really
emphasized
eschatology as they did curology and
ecclesiology yes so let just unack that
please explain
eschatology
is what the Bible says as to how the
future will unfold in terms of the
kingdom of God setting up the kingdom of
God no they just adopted the system of
the Middle Ages church and
state that's why they had to get rid of
the
anabaptists because they were
propagating adult
baptism and that meant that you made a
cognitive decision as to whom you will
serve and you won't immediately
inaugurate it into the church State
system by infant baptism so you're
talking now about protestantism that was
doing this protestantism that was doing
it and not only Protestants got rid of
them but Catholic States as well yes
because they also had a church and state
yes and if you were born you were
registered as part of the church and
state of that particular area and and
you couldn't later decide that you
didn't like that ideology you wanted
another one that's so it actually pulled
through right through to our day yes
that that was enforced that day so you
were born it's actually like tradition
you were born here I'm not going to
change because I'm born like this
correct uh in this church and what did
it lead to led to terrible
persecution and so the people packed
their bags when the opportunity arose
and they fled to the Wilderness they
went to the United States they came to
Africa they went to other parts of the
world where they could Escape The
Tyranny so their eschatology mhm was the
church will rule and set the moral
standards and you will obey okay but
they failed to study it through in the
Bible what they did do a good job on is
curology that is how are you saved how
are you saved how are you saved by grace
by by grace and justification
they got that right because they were at
Lads with Rome as to how you are saved
either by your works or by your faith
through faith so how to be saved in
Christ
theology was a Target area that they
studied ecclesiology is what is the role
of the church in all of this and the
pastor so they emphasize that but they
didn't have a grounded study on
eschatology what does the Bible
say on how it's going to be in the last
days okay so this led to persecution and
atrocities that rivaled those of the
church from which they broke
away it is only when the Constitution of
the United States was formulated that
this kind of religious intolerance
ceased in most Christian
countries sadly the new theologies of
futurism and dispensationalism as
produced by the Jesuits and so pleasing
to the evangelicals are leading Humanity
back to the intolerance that existed in
those days that history termed the Dark
Ages is that a summary of what we've
just spoken about that is very well put
I wonder who wrote
that I don't want to blow my trumpet but
I wrote it no that that is exactly
what's going on that's what's going on
right and if we take this and we look at
the articles that we've just shown you
can put it all in place and see how this
is starting to happen this is starting
to happen they're going back to that why
because they've made the ridiculous so
prominent that this seems to them the
only alternative definitely instead of
preaching truth and converting people to
the true Kingdom they are preaching
dominionism for sure and that is this
part where you said that it's leading
them they they are um milit
yes on this yes they're militant so M
let's go to the biblical view of the
Kingdom it's important that we
understand this so the words kingdom of
God as such do not occur in the Old
Testament however the kingdom is
presented in types of Shadows where the
Kingdom of Israel serves as the type of
the kingdom of God in this Kingdom God
was to be acknowledged as the supreme
ruler m that's the model in the Old
Testament so an example would be 1
Chronicles 29 11 and 12 thine O Lord is
the greatness and the power and the
glory and the Victory and the Majesty
for all that is in heaven and in the
earth is thine thine is the kingdom O
Lord and thou art exalted as head above
all both riches and honor come of thee
and thou reignest Over All and in thine
hand is power and might and in thine
hand it is to make great and to give
strength unto all and Psalms 22:28 says
for the kingdom is the Lord's and he is
the governor among the
Nations all right okay so this is the
concept of the Kingdom we have no King
but Jesus if we can rephrase that we
have no King but God but isn't this that
do they not take these type of um things
in the Bible and make it literal yes
they will they will reintroduce that
davidic concept or the the concept where
God ruled as a
theocracy so Martin if you go to the
prophetic picture and you go to
Daniel and you go to Daniel chapter 2
where you had of course the image
displaying or depicting the kingdoms as
they would come consecutively on Earth
and we read this prophecy then we see
that the image's head was a fine gold
his breast and his arms of silver his
belly and his thighs of brass his legs
of iron and his feet part of iron and
part of
clay that is the progression from
Babylon to me of Persia to Greece to
Rome and to the dividing of Rome into
the states of Europe yes and we don't
have to conjecture on it because the
Bible interprets
itself thou sawest till that a stone was
cut out without hands so here's a divine
intervention a rock yeah without human
mhm interference of any kind which smot
the image upon his
feet not upon the head not upon the rest
of it upon the feet that's the final
Kingdom that's the 10 the 10
that were of iron and clay and broke
them in
pieces so the political systems or the
political religious systems will be
destroyed yeah by the rock that is cut
out not by human means but by divine
intervention that's biblical right
that's biblical
okay then was the iron and the
clay which is church craft and state
craft yeah
the brass the silver the gold broken to
pieces
together why Martin because the the
ideology of Babylon hasn't disappeared
no it's still there the structures of
put in by the MEO Persians merism MH on
which many ecclesiastical Church uh
systems are based hasn't been done away
with Greek philosophy is pervading all
the religious systems Roman law is
pervading it all and state craft and
church craft is
again they're all wanting to come
together and join themselves as one yeah
though they shouldn't be cuz the one
shouldn't cleave to the
other so they were broken in pieces
together and became like cha of the
summer threshing floor and the wind
carried them away that no place was
found for them and the stone that smot
the image became a great mountain and
filled the whole earth so that's the
kingdom of God yeah so according to the
prophecy when does the kingdom of God
come so when Christ destroys all these
kingdoms that's when the kingdom will
come all right so is there room for
dominionism here no there's no room for
it because the kingdom will be set up
when all of it is destroyed so the
church won't rule God Jesus will he will
rule so the kingdom of God will not come
until the Earthly structures whatever
they were throughout history have all
been destroyed yeah and the ideologies
is associated with it is that biblical
yes okay that's what the Bible say all
right let's continue and in the days of
these Kings shall the god of Heaven set
up a kingdom you see will humans be
involved in that no which will never be
destroyed and the kingdom shall not be
left to other people but it shall break
in pieces and consume all the kingdoms
and it shall stand forever is that clear
that's very plainly put I don't think
you can not understand that all right so
is dominionism in harmony with scripture
no unfortunately not what how can you be
so arrogant well I've read what the
Bible
said all right that's your
license to ecclesiastical
arrogance all right the vision of Daniel
7 let's go there
there and I saw in the night vision and
beheld one like the son of man come with
the clouds of heaven and come to the
Ancient of Days and they brought him
near before him this is a event taking
place in heaven right and this is the
title that Jesus Took upon himself when
he was on Earth so he's saying he is the
son of man yeah who in heaven already
was given this power and there was given
him dominion and glory and a kingdom so
where's the
dominionism ah it's his it's his and he
said when he was here the kingdom of God
is near that was what he was here near
is not the same as here many of the
letters are the same but there a
difference between an n and an H yeah
that's and many are pressing in and
there will be persecution and there will
be turmoil and there will be decision
making etc etc but the kingdom is going
to come when when Jesus comes all right
is he already the king yes it's been
given to him he's been coronated he's
been coronated he is already the king
but he hasn't set up his kingdom no he
has to First without human
intervention uh let's rephrase that no
let's emphasize that without human
intervention human saying we'll take the
matter into our own hands he's going to
come and destroy all Earthly setups
and then this prophecy goes into
fulfillment so if I can just put in this
plain sentence there's no president on
Earth that will set up anything that to
sort out anything for God Jesus has to
come and do it no it's an Earthly
attempt which will fail like all the
others did okay in fact this one will
fail horribly because it'll end with
plagues of all right so that all people
and Nations and languages should serve
him not just the Christian nations no
cuz
dominionism has its eyes on the entire
world but uh they they're basically
targeting Christian nations right so his
Dominion is an everlasting Dominion
which shall not pass away and his
kingdom that which shall not be
destroyed that kingdom is it here now no
no but it's a
promise all right let's look at Verse 18
but the Saints of the most high shall
take the kingdom and possess the kingdom
forever and ever even forever and ever
so when do the Saints become part of
this Kingdom only when Jesus comes only
when Jesus comes Daniel 7:22 and the
Ancient of Days came and judgment was
given to the Saints of the most high and
the time came that the Saints possessed
the Kingdom so you see there's no if you
go back to to
dispensationalism there's no there's no
room for it room for it no and judgment
was given to the Saints when will
Judgment be handed to the Saints once
Jesus has come this is just confirming a
judgment that has already taken place
exactly yeah this takes place during the
Millennium yes then they are the ones
that together with Christ determine that
his judgments were true and righteous
are thy judgments
that's what will
happen all right it's a um confirming
judgment a confirming judgment Daniel
7:24 and the 10 horns out of this
Kingdom or 10 kings that shall arise and
another shall rise after them and he
shall be diverse from the first and he
shall subdue three kings all right this
is the the fall of the Roman
Empire and out of the Roman EMP ire 10
Nations will arise three of them will
oppose this other little power that
arises and have to be rooted
out this happened historically yes when
the ruler the vandals and the ostrogoths
were wiped out so that the papacy could
Ascend the papal chair and take upon
himself the heritage of Constantine yeah
also based on fraud by the way and he
shall speak great words against the most
high and shall wear out the Saints of
the most high and think to change times
and laws and they shall be given into
his hand until a time times and the
dividing of time and this time period
you'll find in the Book of Revelation it
refers to the time of papal Supremacy
yes that ended in 1798 where he will
speak great words against the most high
he will remove the atonement of Jesus
Christ is that speaking against the most
high that's complete blasphemy he will
place himself in the place of Christ he
will wear out the Saints and persecute
them did he do that yes did he change
the times and the laws oh yes that's the
main one yes by the way people are
constantly writing to us and saying you
know how do we know that the Sabbath is
still the right day because we're
keeping the Gregorian calendar the
Gregorian calendar never changed the
cycle of the week it just changed the
date that's so important I think it
moved on with what 10 days or something
yes and they shall be given into his
hand for this time period which is of
course the
1,260 days or the three and a half
prophetic Years Day for a year principle
the
1,260 years of papal Supremacy from 538
to
1798 when his secular power was taken
away but the Judgment s s and they shall
take away his dominion and consume and
destroy it unto the end that stone will
come out and will totally destroy the
Earthly
kingdoms and the kingdom and the
Dominion and the greatness of the
Kingdom Under the whole Heaven shall be
given to the people of the Saints of the
most high whose kingdom is an
everlasting Kingdom and all Dominion
Shall Serve and Obey him there'll be
nobody that is opposed to this Kingdom
anymore and nobody's ruling on behalf of
him nobody's ruling on behalf of him
this is the kingdom of God how it will
be set up and when it will be set up all
right that's the Old Testament very
clear yeah let's go to the New
Testament Matthew 3:1 in those days Came
John the Baptist preaching in the
wilderness of Judea and saying repent ye
for the Kingdom of Heaven is at
hand it's available to you yes it's
available to you did Jesus come and
Dethrone caesar no no not literally
no
what all right Mark 1:14 now after that
John was put in prison Jesus came into
Galilee preaching the gospel of the
kingdom of God and saying the time is
fulfilled and the kingdom of God is at
hand repent ye and believe the
gospel it's available to you it's it's
there now it's still available to
everybody today all right uh who is the
king of this Kingdom Jesus the second
temple which was inferior in structure
was greater than the first yes because
the King of Kings walked in it
exactly all right so let's unpack this a
little bit so the Jews expected a
temporal
Kingdom but did not grasp the time
frames nor the nature of the
Kingdom they did not see the suffering
servant predicted in Isaiah nor did they
understand the nature of the cosmic
conflict that was raging and that would
have to reach its culmination before the
kingdom of God could be set
up here was an ideological war that was
put in place and it was put in place
universally everybody got an opportunity
to decide yeah the early disciples
reached China yes they reached Japan
they reached the ends of the world
every nation has had an opportunity and
we'll get another opportunity it's sad
we were just there you the people have
seen it on the previous episode now of
what is truth and if you walk there in
Jerusalem it's still the same yes it
hasn't changed from the first time Jesus
was here now some people are saying you
know we haven't reached the entire world
this gospel will be preached in all the
world and then the end will
come the whole world has cell phones for
sure and the whole world even in the
darkest areas will wear masks when told
to wear them yeah and many will have to
make a decision for or against
Christ isn't that taking place all over
the world
it's like a atomic bomb spreading all
right are people seeing visions yes in
Islamic countries forams Dreaming Dreams
so M this Kingdom that is at hand is
still at hand mhm and you can choose for
it or against it if you choose
dominionism aren't you choosing another
kingdom unfortunately
yes all right Matthew 10:6 but go rather
to the lost sheep of the House of Israel
and as you go preach saying the Kingdom
of Heaven is at
hand now what does that
mean heal the sick cleanse the Le ERS
raise the Dead cast out Devils freely
you have received freely give is that
what they wanted no they wanted they
wanted to get rid of the Romans exactly
they wanted dominionism yes did they get
it no no they didn't get it so the Jews
rejected the spiritual Kingdom rejected
the New Testament and eschatology
leading to the final kingdom of God
they're still waiting to implement
dominionism same thing
John 19:15 but they cried out away with
him away with him crucify him pilate
said unto them shall I crucify your king
that must have driven them insane yeah
the chief priest answers we have no King
but
Caesar and that's typical of what we
have still isn't this exactly what's
happening Matthew 21:42 Jesus said unto
them did you never read in the scripture
this Stone which the builders
rejected the same has become the head of
the corner this is the Lord's doing and
it is marvelous in our
eyes therefore say I say unto you the
kingdom of God shall be taken from you
and given to a nation bringing forth the
fruits thereof so when Jesus died on
that cross and that curtain tore from
top to
bottom and the difference between the
Jew and the Gentile faded in into
Oblivion was that acceptable to them no
no no They carried on or was it a
reality all right did the gospel go to
the Gentiles yes yes and it's
interesting that this same stone that
was rejected will be the one that
destroys those kingdoms yes and it will
be rejected in again in favor of a
counterfeit Stone oh well that's exactly
what's happening so Matthew 23:13 but
woe unto you SC scribes and Pharisees
Hypocrites for you shut up the Kingdom
of Heaven against men for you neither go
in yourselves neither suffer ye them
that are entering to go in so if you
fight against this system you're
fighting against God right yeah the
kingdom of heaven so there is no earthly
Kingdom that's going to be set up other
than Christ will set
yeah all right so would you agree that
these verses clearly indicate that the
Jewish Nation will never fulfill the
kingdom condition
and the Christian church was raised up
as HS to the promises of God yes all
right right were they supposed to
duplicate the mistakes of the Jews the
Christians no yes they won't did they no
they had to learn from the mistakes but
they've done exactly the same they
improved on
them Galatians
6:15 for in Christ Jesus Nei
circumcision Avail us anything nor
uncircumcision but a new creature so
what is God one he doesn't want an
outward form no he wants a change of
heart and as many as walk according to
this rule peace on them and mercy upon
the Israel of God so who is the Israel
of God those with a changed heart that's
it right that's it okay you are chosen
Generation 1 Peter 2:9 a royal
priesthood a holy nation A peculiar
people who's he speaking to to everybody
that had the CH has the change of heart
he's talking to the Christians yeah the
faith in Jesus that you should show
forth the Praises of him who has called
you out of Darkness Into His Marvelous
Light this includes the Jew that wants
to accept this every nation tribe and
people nobody is excluded from this
Choice the Kingdom of Heaven is at hand
make a choice but if you be christs then
you are Abraham's seed and a according
to the promise so you have to be in
Christ in order to attain to the
promises right
you there's no other way there's no
other way so there is no earthly kingdom
here that you can choose you have to
choose a state of heart yeah Revelation
59 and they sung a new song saying Thou
Art Worthy to take the book and to open
the seals thereof for thou was slain and
has redeemed us to God by thy blood out
of every Kindred and tongue and people
and nation is there only one that sets
up the kingdom now yes and that will be
Jesus that's Jesus and none of these
nations everybody has access to the
kingdom and he does not he need any help
he doesn't want a church to do it for
him no because they're going to mess it
up as they have shown over and over in
history and by doing so they will
prevent people from going into the real
Kingdom because they've set up a false
one yeah and he has made us unto our God
God Kings and Priests and we shall reign
on the earth now or in that future
Kingdom in the future do you feel like
you're
reigning no not at all have they in all
these thousands of years succeeded in
reigning no no but they're determined to
try again right so would you agree
Martin that the choice is between two
kingdoms yeah it's the kingdom of God
and the kingdom of
Satan the kingdom
is invading the kingdom of Satan yeah
would you agree with that and he's not
happy with it no not at all because at
this stage and you see that's what
what's interesting he the kingdom of
Earth is actually his yeah because of
all the sin that he's causing and M God
is working very hard to invade this
Kingdom that Satan has set up on this
Earth and Satan is working very hard to
keep him out yes right for sure and he
will set up any counterfeit any
theocracy whether it be of any other
religious system whether it be like in
India where they're trying to set up a
Hindu theocracy or in Islamic countries
where they're trying to set up an
Islamic theocracy or in Christian
countries where they want to set up
dominionism those are all attempts to
keep people out of the real kingdom of
God that's so true so what is Matthew 12
tell us about this but when the
Pharisees heard it they said this fellow
does not cast out Devils but by babo the
prince of the
Devils so when Christ was setting up his
kingdom they said he was the power of
Satan yeah that's how
misconstrued you can be if you don't
follow what the Bible says okay and
Jesus knew their thoughts and said unto
them every Kingdom divided against
itself is brought to desolation
and every city or house divided against
itself shall not stand now if you look
at those dominionist quotes that we had
and those
theologians is it divided some say this
cannot be from God 100% opposite
actually and some say well this is what
we have to do because look at the state
of the world y those two are going to
come into conflict right yep all right
and if Satan cast out Satan he is
divided against himself how shall then
his kingdom stand and if I
by babo cast out Devils by whom do your
children cast them out therefore they
shall be your judges but if I cast out
Devils by the spirit of God then the
kingdom of God Has Come unto you yeah
now is he still casting out Devils out
of people's lives yes yes for sure it's
still a personal choice is it an
enforced choice or is it a free choice
it's a free choice and that's where the
difference is between all the other ones
from Satan and from God okay so can we
say that the kingdom is not political
God's kingdom yes no definitely it's not
political dominionism is it political
yes 100% right John 18:36 Jesus answered
my kingdom is not of this world if my
kingdom were of this world then would my
servants fight and I should not be
delivered to the Jews but now is my
kingdom not
romance it's pretty clear
right pilate therefore said unto him art
thou a king
then Jesus answered thou sayest I'm a
king you said it mhm you're the one who
said it not me you said it so did he
deny it that he was a king no no he
actually confirmed it confirmed it yes
all right to this end was I born and for
this cause came I into the world that I
should bear witness unto the truth
everyone that is of the truth heareth my
voice
and this Gospel of the Kingdom shall be
preached in all the world for a witness
unto all nations and then shall the End
come so this Kingdom near will not be
replaced by the kingdom until Christ has
come yeah because he's already King and
he will bring his kingdom to Earth not
not it will be set up here by some Earth
about humans yes so he came as king but
he didn't come to replace Caesar right
he was inaugurated as King in a mock
ceremony mhm the title was placed above
his cross right yeah Matthew 2:2 saying
where is he that is born King of the
Jews with the Magi yes asking for I I've
been told that it's
Maki what Mahi not Magi okay but uh
maybe I'm even wrong in that
pronunciation the men from the
East for we have seen his star in the
east and are come to worship Him did
they know that the king of the the Jews
actually it says judeans in the original
was born yes where did they get it from
from prophecy they must have studied
Daniel's prophecies right and Jesus
stood before the governor Matthew 27 and
the governor asked him saying art thou
the King of the Jews and Jesus said to
him thou
sayest and then when they had planted
the crown of thorns they put it upon his
head and a reed in his right hand and
they bowed the knee before him and
mocked him saying hail King of the
Jews in a mock ceremony he was still
acknowledged he was still acknowledged
right they even put a scepter in his
hand and then on his cross and set up
over his head his accusation written
this is is Jesus king of the Jews King
of the
judeans and they went to Pilot and said
don't say that and he said what I've
written I've written you're too
late Martin this is this is the
inauguration the Earthly inauguration
there was a Heavenly one exactly from
here on and then there was a
confirmation that the sacrifice was
accepted and since that time everybody
has been pressing into the kingdom or
rejecting it by their choice yeah and
it's going to remain like that until he
comes and that will stay like that till
Michael stands up and Jesus puts on his
kingly attire correct in other words the
judgment will have been completed and he
will come to execute judgment yeah and
bring his reward yes so we do have a
king but he doesn't have an Earthly
Kingdom it's not of this world at this
stage
so the Everlasting kingdom of God is
inaugurated only after the Millennium
because this Earth is destroyed at the
coming of Christ a judgment of
verification takes place in heaven
judgment is handed to the Saints go and
check it out whether my judgments are
fair true and just are your judgments
will be the Declaration just make that
clear because it's important because of
all we've said that that when Jesus
comes to take the Saints there the
Judgment must have been executed already
because there are Saints and they are
lost and then there's nothing left on
Earth nothing the C are broken down
according to the Book of Revelation all
the cities of the Nations fell there's
nothing left of so the kingdom is then
in heaven with him yes and then after
the M they will rule with him a thousand
years and then he returns to Earth but
it's not on Earth the ruling no then the
city comes down and lands on this Earth
there's a resurrection of the unjust
there's a final judgment a fire of
Destruction and a setting up of the
final Kingdom which will last forever
and ever and ever and it's a postm
millennial Kingdom and Christ is the
king reigning there yes so we can say
that at the second coming of Christ the
Saints are Tak away to heaven where
Mansions have been prepared for them
right Revelation 211 and I saw a new
Heaven and a new Earth for the first
Heaven and the first Earth were passed
away and there was no more
sea so that has not taken place yet
right and I John saw the holy city the
New Jerusalem coming down from God out
of Heaven prepared as a bride adorned
for a husband
and I heard a great voice out of Heaven
saying behold the Tabernacle of God is
with men and he will dwell with them and
they shall be his people and God himself
shall be with them and be the God is
that dominionism no no because God is
excluded they're doing it on behalf
they're doing it supposedly on behalf of
him and there shall in no wise enter it
anything that defileth neither
whatsoever worketh Abomination or maketh
a lie but they which are written in the
Lamb's Book of Life this is the kingdom
Maria and it's not going to be
dominionism and he showed me a pure
River of Water of Life clear as Crystal
proceeding out of the Throne of God and
of the lamb and in the midst of the
street of it and on either side of the
river was there the Tree of Life which
be 12 manner of fruits and yielded a
fruit every month and the leaves of the
trees were for the healing of the
Nations is that happening now no not at
all and there shall be no more curse but
the Throne of God that's the
kingdom and of the Lamb shall be in it
and his servants Shall Serve him and
they shall see his face and his name
shall be in their foreheads in other
words their character yeah will be in
harmony with his
character Revelation 22:16 and I jesus
sent my angel to testify unto you these
things in the churches I am the root and
The Offspring of David and the bright
and Morning Star in other words if he's
The Offspring of David he's the king in
the kingly line and the spirit and the
bride say come the mar God doesn't do
anything independent of his church so
the Holy Spirit together with the bride
the church inviting people to accept
this Kingdom and let him that heareth
say come and let him that is a thirst
come and whosoever will is there any
Force there no and it is open to
everybody let him take the Water of Life
freely but this is biblical
eschatology did protestantism delve into
this no unfortunately not they stuck on
Domin ISM and dispensation whatever
whatever system they inherited whatever
they think is going to work for them
this is biblical eschatology you cannot
override it no you cannot set up your
own
system so in other words can we say that
no human being can make a new Heaven and
a new Earth Only God Can of course so
the kingdom will only be there when
there is a new Heaven and a new Earth so
anything other than that is counterfeit
that's it
all human effort to set up the kingdom
of Glory while the kingdom of Grace
abounds is futile would you agree with
that yes human beings can no more build
this Kingdom than they can save
themselves brilliantly put thank you
because otherwise you become a God again
you become a god unto yourself so right
now we are sitting with Matthew 11:28
come unto me all ye that labor and are
heavy laden and I will give your rest
that's the kingdom of that's available
to us now it is near but it will be set
up only when Christ returns amen all
right Martin so let's just go into a
little bit of
typology just to wrap it up just briefly
so the Old Testament battles serve as a
type of the final confrontation that
will take place between Earthly systems
M which will be destroyed by The Rock
which is
Christ and Heavenly
systems so every Earthly support will be
cut off and they can neither buy nor
sell we read that in Revelation 1317
right that's what's going to come yes so
when they set up
dominionism and you don't go along with
their system there will be economic
measures taken against you yes and we
everything everything is in place the
digital IDs all of those things God's
people will be in dial Straits the whole
world will be array against them
according to Revelation 13 3 and2 is
that correct yes so you're not going to
you're going to have everybody against
you isn't this very different from
dominionism where God's people are
ruling and and you know calling the
shots no it's much different than that
all right there will be a death decree
pronounced against them those that keep
the Commandments and hold to the
testimony will by dominionism be
sentenced to death exactly so to to try
and reverse it to say where will the
death Greek go against dominionism then
it can't can't it's a total Haywire
system was there a death decree against
Jesus yes because his kingdom didn't
Jael with their Kingdom right exactly
yeah so we're going to have the
same all they can do is trust that he
will save them by promise all they can
do is say the following Oh Our God wil
thou not judge them for we have no might
against this great company that comes
against us neither know we what to do
but our eyes are upon thee so who are
this is talking about the remnant Church
yes what they are in Dire Straits in the
last days they're not sitting on the
throne calling the shots exactly it's
the exact opposite of what they're
promising right that's exactly the
opposite there's no saving coming out of
this whole system we're going to be
persecuted
okay so the only way to face the coming
crisis is to remember beautiful that's
what we talked about last
time so he's the Potter we are the clay
he's the Creator we are the creature not
until we realize our total dependence
and find nothing within ourselves to
commend us
can we truly rest in him and this is the
meaning of the Sabbath it is a sign that
we acknowledge that he is the Lord that
sanctifies us and when we do that the
whole world will be ar raay against us
exactly including the
dominionism so Ezekiel 20:12 says
moreover I gave them my sabbaths to be
assigned between me and them that they
might know that I am the Lord that
sanctify them thy will be done as in
Earth on Earth Earth as it is in heaven
thy kingdom
come we've discussed that God's angels
keep the
Commandments and God's people will keep
the Commandments will they come into
conflict with the kingdom of the world
yes because they want to enforce their
Commandments
aha so God is the helper of the true
Remnant and they will sing a new song
when they are delivered right
Revelation 7:14 I said unto him sir thou
knowest and he said unto me these are
they which come out of the Great
Tribulation they have washed their robes
and made them white in the blood of the
Lamb so they have been
Justified and
Sanctified and they sing the song of
Moses which is a song of physical
deliverance from slavery yeah servant of
God and the of the Lamb which is a song
of spiritual
Deliverance great and marvelous are thy
Works Lord God Almighty just and true
are thy ways Thou King of saints who
shall not fear thee Oh Lord and glorify
thy name for thou only art holy for all
nations shall come and worship before
thee for thy judgments are made
Manifest this is what will happen in the
end and the judgments come before the
Kingdom M and only when those judgments
have been made manifest can we sing a
new song yeah not before not before so
Martin I hope
that the viewers will understand that
there will be no earthly Kingdom before
the Heavenly kingdom is set up that is
biblical
eschatology and anything that is
contrary to it is a false rendition yeah
of of what the scripture is saying may
God help us may God help us let's pray
Heavenly
Father we are seeing the culmination of
History it is like a a movie being
portrayed before our very eyes the only
difference is that this is
reality and very soon there will be a
choice between the kingdom of the world
and the kingdom of heaven and those that
want to set up an Earthly Kingdom will
say it is
expedient that we remove those that are
opposed to our kingdom because then our
Dominion will be taken away without
realizing that it has already been taken
away and will be physically taken away
when that rock strikes the
statue and the wind takes it away like
dust so help us to understand these
things and to choose the right Kingdom
in jesus' name amen amen
[Music]